no sólo para el presidente trump sino
por décadas él ha elevado a mujeres a
posiciones altas tanto en los negocios
como en el gobierno él confía en
nosotros respeta nuestra opinión e
insiste en que nosotros estamos
equiparados a nivel de los hombres el
presidente entró al text me ayudó a
romper una barrera en la política
dándome el poder para manejar su campaña
de manera exitosa con la ayuda de
millones de estadounidenses nuestro
equipo se desafió los críticos en we
want y ganamos fue mediadas wind para
muchos de nosotros
el empoderamiento femenino no es un
slogan no viene de los medios sociales
viene de todos y las heroínas que nos
criaron y que creyeron en nosotros sus
ventajas yo fui criada en una casa donde
todos eran mujeres en mi siguiente
airlive sus vidas no fueron fáciles pero
nunca se quejaron
el dinero era poco pero teníamos
abundancia lo que más importante la
familia fe y libertad ail dónde yo
aprendí que en eeuu es nada
berlin de jeans de promesa de la promesa
de eeuu nos pertenece a todos esta es
una tierra de inventores innovadores de
emprendedores y educadores de pioneros y
padres que brin cada uno contribuyendo
al éxito y el futuro de una gran nación
y de su pueblo dice
también el presidente de cher y
profesora que tomó tiempo extra para
ayudar a sus estudiantes para que se
acomodaran de manera virtual las
enfermeras que terminaban un turno de 12
horas sólo tomaban un tiempo corto sólo
para cambiar sus guantes y sus
mascarillas para volver a empezar
los emprendedores que abrieron su
negocio
es una vez más luego de la pandemia y de
la del caos
a quienes finalmente después de 10 años
tienen un seguro social primer game
reciente trump y el vicepresidente de
bens han dado dignidad y resultados a
eeuu he visto de primera mano muchas
veces offering el presidente confortando
ya ayudando a un niño que ha perdido a
un padre a un padre que ha perdido a un
niño a un trabajador que perdió su
trabajo
a un adolescente
que perdió su camino en las drogas les
ha dicho no pierdan la esperanza
asegurándoles que no están solos y que
ellos importan de weiss ellos siempre
van a ser personas
y nuestra responsabilidad es enfocarnos
en aquellos que tienen menos que
nosotros
el presidente de trump a eso
precisamente eso será el action tomar
acciones sin precedentes para combatir
la crisis de drogas en este país me ha
dicho que esto es tan importante que ya
no se tantas vidas han sido renovadas
por la adicción y nosotros ni siquiera
lo sabemos porque la gente le da
vergüenza a pedir ayuda y no saben a
quién pedir ayuda en sus peores momentos
en vez de mirar para el otro lado el
presidente del pse es miro a la crisis
de la droga directamente y creando una
legislación para asegurar la inversión
en seguridad en educación en prevención
tratamiento y recuperación en la que
tenemos un gran camino por recorrer
pero la el en 'science en estigma y el
estigma que previene a la gente de pedir
ayuda se está desvaneciendo
y este es el hombre que conozco y el
presidente que necesitamos por otros
cuatro años más
él toma las luchas más difíciles
y combate él me ha apoyado y él los va a
apoyar a ustedes de weening en honor de
las mujeres que me empoderaron y por el
futuro de los niños que todos queremos
gracias y dios los bendiga siempre